hello everyone and welcome to today's
video on top marketing strategies in
2024 do you know that in 2024 marketing
strategies had evolved to meet the
dynamic demands of everchanging digital
landscape embracing cutting Technologies
and consumer Centric approaches
businesses are poised to navigate the
competitive terrain with Innovative and
impactful campaigns from the Resurgence
of SEO with a focus on Rich Snippets and
mobile friendliness to the Renaissance
of influencer marketing the stres of the
Year reflect a nuanced understanding of
a consumer Behavior additionally hyper
localized campaigns and the integration
of sustainability as a core brand value
underscores the importance of relevance
and social responsibility with that said
guys before we move on I have a just
quick info for you simply learn has got
the post-graduate program in
collaboration with the Purdue University
you can become the certified digital
marketer from the Purdue University you
will learn to create and promote your
your own website via live Interactive
Learning you'll Master basic and
advanced digital marketing skills via
stti simulation 10 plus case studies 20
plus projects chat GPT AI tools and 35
Plus DM tools now before we move on and
learn about the top marketing strategies
in 2024 I request you guys that do not
forget to hit the Subscribe button and
click the Bell icon so guys let's start
with the top marketing strategies in
2024 the first strategy that we have all
over here is video content so guys as we
all know that in 2024 the dominance of
video content continues to ascend
solidifying its status as the premium
medium short form videos captivating
audiences on social platforms showcases
the medium's dynamic and engaging nature
meanwhile long form video essays gain
prominence for their ability to both
educate and entertain offering a
versatile and immersive experience as
this technology evolves we all know that
video's adaptability and ability to
convey information in diverse format
ensures its unmatched appeal making it
an indispensable tool for communication
entertainment and education in the
digital landscape the continual rise of
video in 2024 signifies its enduring
influence and adaptability in ever
evolving media landscape so this is one
of the most prominent marketing strategy
that I've have been seeing in
2024 let's move on and disc discuss
about our second marketing strategy and
I hope so you would have heard about it
it's called as personalization 2.0
Precision at scale in the era of
personalization 2.0 technological
strides have revolutionized
customization AI driven insights Empower
Brands to meticulously tellor
individualized experiences on expansive
scale transcending generic approaches
and this Precision at scale not only
enhances the customer engagement but
also for Fosters and unwavering loyalty
brand harnesses the power of datadriven
intelligence to anticipate and fulfill
unique preferences creating a seamless
and personalized Journey for each
customer and as a technology evolves we
all know that personalization 2.0 marks
a transformative shift where Brands
leverage Their audience on profound and
individual level setting new standards
for customer Centric strategies in the
digital age next we have all over here
is Voice Search
optimization cracking the vocal code can
also benefit your business we all know
that the rise of voice activated devices
has reshaped the search Paradigm
emphasizing the importance of voice
search optimization in
2024 crafting content that align
seamlessly with conversational queries
become Paramount as users increasingly
interact with technology through spoken
language to maintain visibility and this
evolving landscape business must
optimize their online presence for voice
search Deering the nuances of spoken
queries strategic keyword selection
natural language integration and focus
on contextually relevant response have
become essential elements in cracking
the vocal code as voice interaction
become more and more prevalent adapting
to these shifts ensure Brands stay at
the Forefront of accessible and
userfriendly digital experiences I hope
so you would have got an idea that
implementing voice search optimization
can be a game changer for your business
now next we have ai powered chatbots we
all know that in 2024 AI powered
chatbots are redefining customer
interaction which are emerging as an
indispensible tools for businesses and
these intelligent BS are driven by
artificial intelligence which offer
instantaneous and personalized support
addressing queries and also adaptly
guiding their users their significance
lies in continuous learning from each
interaction enabling them to evolve and
enhance their responses over the time
the efficiency and accessibility of Aid
driven chatbots are streamlining
customer service providing Around the
Clock assistance and improving the user
experiences as these boards become more
sophisticated they not only boost
operational efficiency but also
contribute to building lasting customer
relationships this making a
transformative shift in the landscape of
customer engagement and support and it's
one of the most Innovative strategies
that I have seen businesses are
implementing in
2024 now let's move on and discuss about
our next strategy which is Emeral
content or the foro strategy I hope so
you have heard about foro if I'm correct
foro stands for fear of missing out foro
emerges as a compiling marketing
strategy in
2024 its transient nature available only
for limited time triggers a sense of
urgency among the audiences stories and
posts that vanish create an immediate
and time sensitive alure fostering
higher engagement as users fear missing
out and exclusive or time bound
experiences this Dynamic approach not
only captivates attention but also
prompts immediate actions such as clicks
shares and purchases in the evolving
landscape of digital content consumption
leveraging ephemeral content as foro
strategy proves effective in maximizing
audience engagement and also
capitalizing on the psychology of
urgency next we have all over here guys
is
sustainability so in 2024 sustainability
has emerged as a Cornerstone of brand
identity fostering profound connections
with an environmentally conscious
audience as societal awareness about the
environment intensifies Brands embracing
sustainability have gained the
prominence incorporating eco-friendly
practices have become imperative from
supply chain decision to product
packaging transparent communication
about these initiatives not only
enhances brand credibility but also
resonates with consumers seeking ethical
and responsible choices in this era of
heightened environmental Consciousness
Brands prioritizing sustainability align
with shifting consumer values
cultivating trust and loyalty the
integration of sustainable practices is
no longer optional it is an essential
strategy for Brands aiming to thrive in
an eco-aware Marketplace next we have
all over here in our catalog that is
influencer marketing we all know that a
renaissa influencer marketing unfolds in
2024 as marked by a shifts toward
authenticity and relevance if I talk
about Nano and micro influencers with
their genuine connections to Niche
audiences also claim the spotlight
Brands recognize the power of these
small scale influencers as their
authenticity resonates deeply with the
emphasis on pirates from macro
celebrities to relatable figures
fostering more genuine connections macro
and micro influencers ability to convey
authenticity and relatability positions
them as a valuable Partners in targeted
marketing strategies reflecting a Nuance
approach to influencer collaborations
that align seamlessly with diverse and
Discerning preferences of contemporary
consumers next we have all over here one
of the most popular one and I prefer
this as most amazing tools which I've
seen in the e-commerce platforms a lot
this is augmented reality so we all know
that augmented reality is set to
redefine consumer experiences enabling
Brands to create immersive encounters
leveraging AR Brands can Empower
customers to visualize products within
their personal environments before
committing to a purchase this
transformative approach Bridges the gap
between online and offline shopping
enhancing consumer confidence by
offering a tangible preview of how
products fit into their lives from
trying on Virtual clothing to placing
Furniture in Living Spaces AR provides a
dynamic and interactive Dimension to the
shopping process unlocking a new era of
personalized and engaging consumer
interaction that go beyond traditional
e-commerce boundary AR has proven to be
one of the most effective strategies in
2024 now let's move on and discuss about
our ninth strategy and this is one of
the most effective strategies which I've
seen in
2024 which is hyper localized campaigns
in 2024 there was a rise of hyper
localized campaigns which are
transforming the marketing strategies
through precise and Geo targeting Brands
recognize the importance of specific
regions and cultures fostering a more
personalized and resonant connection
with diverse audiences by understanding
local preferences these campaigns go
beyond generic approaches speaking
directly to the unique needs and
interest of each Community the result is
a heighten level of relatability as
Brands demonstrate a nuanced
understanding of the local context
embracing hyper localization ensures
that marketing efforts not only reach
but genuinely connect with consum
consumers establishing a more meaningful
presence in the intricacies of regional
diversity now let's move on and discuss
about our final strategy and you have
heard about this word a lot and it is
SEO or search engine
optimization in
2024 SEO experiences have researched
adapting to a Google's evolving
algorithms Rich Snippets and schema
markup languages have emerged as pivotal
elements providing search engines with
structure data to enhance result
visibility and user understanding mobile
friendliness remains Paramount giving
increasing Reliance on smartphones for
online searches as Google prioritizes
user experience websites optimized for
mobile devices gain an edge in search
ranking this new er of SEO emphasizes
not only keyword relevance but also the
delivery of high quality context-rich
content adapting to these factors
becomes imperative for businesses
striving to secure top positions in
search engine result and remain visible
in the ever evolving digital landscape
with that said guys we have come to the
end of this video I hope so you would
have enjoyed our today's video on top
marketing strategies that we should
Implement in
2024 staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here